J'ai juste une telle adrénaline à cause de ça
Je tire et quand ils ont acheté 50 Kupala
c'est la deuxième fois
le centre a récemment ouvert ses portes
de l'enseignement pédagogique national De
lycéens en cours de défense
de l'Ukraine ont la possibilité
compétences pratiques à acquérir C'est comme ça
pistolet à fusil stomatique, c'est-à-dire
topographie militaire se familiariser avec
sécurité variable et apprendre la règle
manipulation des armes
C'est extraordinaire
étude intéressante et nécessaire, car médicale
nous pouvons fournir toute aide
le moment où une personne s'est sentie malade
on saura déjà quoi faire pour que ce soit possible
sauvons sa vie
[musique]
maintenant j'apprends à piloter un drone. Nous avons
plusieurs ordinateurs sur lesquels nous travaillons
tout le monde
le transimulator est actuellement très connu
programme
et quelque chose pour voler
[musique]
même si la victoire arrivera bientôt
une telle compétence sera toujours nécessaire dans
la vie et comme nous le savons, la guerre continue
au moment où cette compétence expire
peut être nécessaire à ceux qui vont partir
dans les affaires militaires
[musique]